as a small group of protesters prayed
hundreds waited for tickets to the
unveiling of an 8ft tall bronze statue
of a goat-headed Satan I'm just excited
to see my Lord and Savior bamet
represented in such glorious Italian
Stone Satan's pretty
cool assemble the
[Applause]
Army Professor Jacob and producer Davies
insisted that I take on the vice
documentary uh praising Satanism
fight hi my name is Zeke apolon and I am
the chapter head for the Satanic Temple
London and UK
welcome I think What attracted me most
to Satanism was just I think how
Preposterous a lot of stuff that was
coming from people who called themselves
Christians these people are extremists
they're religious extremists these guys
they believe in their magical Sky Daddy
and they pray with their family and they
put on a nice jacket and go to church on
Sunday and worship God goodness truth
and beauty and it's just so silly that's
why I go out into the woods and we're
dark robes and worship goat demons
because Christianity is so Preposterous
some of these people have blood on their
hands and so I figured if they could do
horrible things in the name of Jesus
then I could do wonderful things in the
name of of Satan what horrible things do
people do in the name of
Jesus well we're waiting I've heard that
before people have done horrible things
in the Name of
Christ like what like what I promise you
every single one of those satanists in
this video supports abortion so they all
support basically the worst thing you
could possibly imagine on Earth killing
little innocent babies you're a monster
what are the worst things they accuse
the Christians of doing they accuse the
Christians today of telling
sexually disordered people to shape up
and do things that are more conducive to
their flourishing they try to ban
pornography okay they try to preserve
the family what did they do they'll even
historically they'll say well you know
they've done ter they fought the
Crusades the Crusades were good they
were the Crusades were defensive
military actions to stop the the Muslims
from raping and destroying people and
civilizations specifically in the Holy
Land it's amazing these same people
they'll say we have to go bomb Syria and
depose the regime there because of human
rights violations you want to hear what
the Muslims were doing at the time of
the Crusades give me a break I don't
think I've ever felt as in my own skin
as I do as a Satanist because I believe
that yeah I mean part of it is looking
at like ugly sides of yourself and being
able to sort of Rec reconcile that and
looking at ugly sides of humanity in
terms of misconceptions about satanists
I think you know people think that we
sacrifice babies we are engaged in some
kind of like you know underground sex
trafficking and
yeah you are I've definitely met some
babies that I haven't really gotten on
with very well but I've never actually
killed
one you get it but you have you're not
fooling anyone at least indirectly
because if you support abortion as a
political matter which all of these
people do then you are involved in the
killing of babies wholesale Slaughter of
babies and by the way EV every single
abortion clinic in the United States has
a satanic Covenant attached to it and
you might say that's crazy that's a cult
there's no way that stuff really happens
look at these people you think these
people wouldn't do that maybe if it's
not these people if it's the more
hardcore if they're the more semi-ironic
satanists the hardcore ones are you
could speak you hear testimony from
former satanists who who talk about this
frequently even just that he I mean I
don't like every baby I meet but you
know I wouldn't kill any of them but you
do would you vote for a pro-abortion
politician or a pro-life politician so
you you not only would but you do
through your vote there's a little girl
in the window right
there Bad Touch Bad Touch stranger
danger for me Satanism is really about
not letting myself off the hook you know
and and I believe for me that being a
Satanist is about trying to continually
advocate for people especially people
who aren't able to advocate for
themselves I'd be willing to just from
this brief interview we've heard from
this guy I bet he's into some weird
stuff so they they are of course this is
just what Pagan Cults do I mean this is
been every this is what a bakan Alan
orgy is right you go out into the woods
and you get weird this is what the
Israelites were doing when Moses went up
the mountain to talk to God what did
they do they immediately start
worshiping the golden calf but
worshiping the golden calf doesn't mean
you're just standing there like bowing
down to a golden calf it means you're
doing all sorts of really depraved
things the point of which is to do
whatever you want it's the thing he said
at the very beginning he said it's just
about doing whatever you want it's about
fulfilling your own selfish desires and
yeah that is that is what Satanism is
and there are two groups of satanists
there are the really conscious satanists
who understand that they're worshiping a
spiritual being and there are the ironic
satanists for whom Satan is merely a
symbol but the end result for both is
the behavior is the same thing which is
to just do whatever you want it's the
line from alist Crowley do as thou will
will be the entirety of the law some of
the weirdest interactions are people who
like send us satanic prayers people will
sometimes ask us to pass on messages to
the devil and I'm like we're not the
devil's answering
service oh I got a live one Satanism is
a love affair with the self
actually I think one of the things that
the satanic temple wants to do is
actually sponsor an orgy we would be
there as people who would fold the
towels and we would uh make sure that
there was enough like condoms and mov
and we would like provide sex education
you know a lot of us are trained um some
of us are medics um and what we would do
is
facilitate what would be like a safe
consensual group sex practice for people
and it would benefit
something this is the irony of the
satanists when you're consciously just
pursuing your own self-interest without
regard for anyone else or for God or for
virtue or for justice ironically you are
undermining your own self-interest you
are Your Own Worst Enemy you saw there
the last frames of a a person I assume a
man maybe a woman dressed up as a dog
with his tongue hanging out when you
equate self interest with your base
desires you just degrade yourself you
turn yourself into an animal the thing
that distinguishes us from the animals
is our our intellect and our reason so
when you turn off your reason and say
you know it's probably not good for for
me to pretend to be a dog and to abuse
my body and to do all sorts of depraved
things when you turn your reason off or
ignore it and you just follow your
selfish self-interested animal will then
you degrade yourself into an animal
whoever would
pursue their their true
self-interest must must stop focusing on
the
self simple as
that Rick nicholby reporting live from a
gruesome scene a cult known as qet or
quest for Eternal truth has apparently
taken their own lives in a mass suicide
hi Rick Nichols B Channel 6 hi were you
two members of The Cult that lived here
the cult what cult was this a cult right
I had no idea this was a cult although I
will say the term cult it's a little
judgmental I would say the same thing
not knowing the full
Doctrine